hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the use of a CD 200r inhibitor
to overcome central nervous system
tumor-induced immunosuppression I am
Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
language and sponsored by
immunochemistry technologies immuno
chemistry technologies provides quality
laboratory service and research reagents
as a contract service laboratory ICT
specializes in custom immunoassay
development manufacturing conjugation
lyophilization and consulting services
ICT is focused on Eliza development and
has the knowledge to develop reliable
sensitive and specific tests ICT offers
align Eliza diluents including code
buffers conjugates safe stabilizers and
sample dillion ones designed to reduce
backgrounds increase the specific signal
and improve the stability and shelf-life
of the eliza ICT also offers a line of
fluorescent reagents to measure caps ace
activity apoptosis and cell death in
vitro for more information please visit
WWE you have a few announcements before
we begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window to let us know or
submit your problem to the green Q&A
button lower left this presentation has
been approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the cee button
at the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr.
michael pollan dr. Michael Owen is an
assistant professor in the department of
pediatrics at the University of
Minnesota his research is primarily
dedicated to developing immunotherapy
for brain tumors he utilizes tumor cells
as vaccine components demonstrating
promising results with minimal toxicity
dr. Owen received his PhD in 2005 from
the University of Minnesota's veterinary
medicine program I will now turn it over
to Michael for his presentation well
thank you very much please bear with me
I have a little bit of a Minnesota cold
so I'll try not to cough and make anyone
sick over the Internet my lab focuses
mainly on immunotherapy immunology and
ways we can exploit the immune system to
overcome tumor-induced immune
suppression and we've been doing this
with some success over the last few
years so basically the progression to a
productive immune response involves
passing a number of what's called amia
logical checkpoints and these
checkpoints are called checkpoint
blockades in other words when they
recognize self tumor cells or nitrogen
from the tumor like we give as the
vaccines they can actually shut down the
immune system and inhibiting the ability
of ass to mouth and antitumoral response
so people have been looking at ways to
overcome this induction of immune
tolerance through what's called
checkpoint blockades and one of the more
famous one right now is an anti ctla4 or
looking at the ctla4 see if I can do
this blockade here which shuts down
which shuts down on a t-cell activation
another one is um is called through
program death Ligon one its receptor pd1
in other words the tumor to sell
can actually exploit this in the tumor
microenvironment virtually shutting down
in act or in activating t cells so
people have been looking at this with
with some success by deriving antibodies
humanized antibodies against the ctla4
and the pd-1 inhibiting these reactions
and in listening in immune response and
they've been doing this with some
success specifically in melanoma well
we're chasing down a third amia logical
checkpoint called cd200 cd200 and its
interaction on the city 200
receptor-induced antigen presented jen
cell tolerance inhibiting the ability to
make an immune response or illicit in
immune response so basically what cd200
is this extremely immunosuppressive
protein it negatively regulates the
immune system where it shuts it down a
lot of preliminary studies on graph um
rejections show that if you give mouse
um cd200 protein will never reject gum
graph it shuts down the immune system
totally and that's through binding on
its receptors which are Miley Miley
mostly on myeloid cells however
following TCR activation the cd200
receptor is upregulated on T cells which
we'll get into that problem and a little
bit where a little bit later this talk
so like I said earlier tumors induce
suppression multiple this multiple
mechanisms multiple ways that the tumors
capable of this and one of them is
through antigen presentation now
gorsinski and are reported that the CD
200 and its receptor interactions
induces tolerogenic dc's and this really
spark
interests because we want to inhibit the
seduction of tolerogenic he sees to
elicit an immune response moreover it's
been suggested that City 200 expands
what's called a myeloid-derived
suppressor cell population which induces
immune suppression I'll be showing you
some data that we've done in-house and
I'd actually published showing that this
is indeed true now in the central
nervous system this is hot neurons
highly regulate the cd200 and that's to
inhibit activation of t-cells that you
don't want in the central nervous system
and it's been reported that
downregulation or the loss of the city
200 correlated with increases in ms as
well as Alzheimer's it's also been shown
that cd200 is expressed on multiple
tumors including melanoma can create at
breast cancer and what we're interested
is glioblastoma multiforme a or a CNS
disaster so we started looking in
unhealthy donated from CNS is that
autopsy and we showed that cd200 is
highly expressed at least by
transcription throughout most of the
central nervous system and you can see
here you can see here in brown on the
brown that's protein levels in the
normal central nervous system of cd200
now this isn't true in peripheral in
peripheral organs such as breast kidney
liver pancreas and lungs you can see
that there's relatively low expression
of cd200 so we went on and showed that
through multiple um CNS tumors such as
meningioma clio blasts obama thief or
nay
Oh blast Alma's etc etc you get high
transcription or computer meningioma
switch is in a typical see an estimate
you get high transcription of the CD 200
protein so we decided to look at the
potential use of this in a needle
therapy now you know because the CD 200
receptor interactions have been
demonstrated although there's some
controversy over this that they enhance
metastasis of breast tumors and multiple
myeloma and has been reported that
blocking the city 200 receptor actually
has shown to be decreased tumor growth
although like I said there's a little
bit of controversy over that we're
trying to figure it out right now so
there has been clinical trials using an
anti cd200 where this company targets
the CD 200 on the tumor cells on the
tumor itself in b-cell chronic
lymphocytic leukemia and multiple
myeloma however there's not much talked
about or there's no follow-up on the
outcomes of this program so we think
this is because what we discover just
recently that you can see the brown in
normal I'll Constitution cd200 and
staining of brown you see very little of
this on the tumor itself especially high
grade glioblastoma multiforme eggs and
that's due to the protein being pleased
by adam 28 protease so we think that
targeting the tumor itself the CD to la
jolla tumor will not be efficacious
because it's solubilized and that
correlates with some patient data
including ours or wrong at all showed or
reported that it's a soluble seeding 200
that regulates or correlates
for patient outcome and we reported this
earlier this year where we took patient
samples from an ongoing or a finished
University clinical trial of ours on
gliomas and i also had serum samples
from some friends colleagues of mine
where we show that in glioblastoma
multiforme a there's some kind of some
patients had high levels of cd200 in
there Sarah now what was interesting
there are these patients correlated with
real aggressive act of disease if you
look further on this graph this module
Oh blessed all but was a patient of our
clinical trial that we just reported and
this was at the point where she actually
went off trial because she had rapid
progression of her disease but what was
very interesting and caught our
attention was within all these
ependymomas one of the pet imola
patients was on our trial and when she
came in she had relatively low
concentrations of cd200 and she actually
responded to our therapy was pretty
exciting but what had happened was when
she we could have me occurrence at week
eight her CD 200 level significantly
increased from her baseline and then
when she had her spinal Mets that even
went up further moreover you can see
that this increase in soluble sitting
200 correlated with an increase of her
myeloid-derived suppressor cell
population as she went off trial so when
her tumor came back its I'll utilized
the CD 200 this is what I patha sizing
and it increased her md's mdse levels as
she progressed occurred the disease
progressed and this was true with our
glioblastoma
multi-format patients as well so we
asked the question how can we block
cd200 induce immune suppression and in
DSC expansion well what it turns out is
that this this is our hypothesis right
now this is on working hypothesis in my
lab there are some holes in a story
because it's ongoing research but what
we've shown or what's out in the
literature actually is there's a cd200 r
1 receptor 1 and there's isoforms which
I turned r2 r3 and r4 well it turns out
at least in the literature and we're
testing this right now that the cd200
protein itself which is extremely
immunosuppressive binds to the cd200
receptor and delivers an inhibitory
signal through a doc pathway doc wanted
to these do not bind to cd200 receptor
two three or four or the isoforms at
least this is what's told in the
literature today so gorsinski reported
that if you took a peripheral blood from
two donors and added them together and
induced what's called a mixed leukocyte
reaction you could induce a sin oolitic
response he's also measured this by
interfering gamma excuse me and he
showed that if you add the protein the
city 200 you can inhibit the production
of a cytolytic response which has been
shown as an immunosuppressant but what
he started doing is he looked at
crystallography and he actually looked
at regions of the cd200 protein itself
which when he added to the mixture you
either got this agganis was he's turning
as agganis response or inhibitory
response the same as the protein but was
interested
is different regions of the protein you
got it antagonist response or it
overcame the suppressive effects so we
started looking at these these and what
we're hypothesizing and this is
hypothesis based off when aggression
skis literature or manuscripts as well
is that potentially these peptides bind
to the isoforms and these isoforms
actually activate and in turn out well
activate in immune response so to me
that well what kind of going back on
this antagonist versus Agnes right now
but for this presentation right now
until we totally characterize it we are
going to call these CD towards you
receptor antagonists so that's that's
the terminology I'm going to use for the
rest of the UM the rest of the talk so
we decided to test these antagonists and
we went back and actually derived
different peptides based off
crystallography but what we showed is
that if we give a mouse a glioma and we
vaccinated with only the peptides that
see the dillinger except I taking us on
day two and i'll talk about why we have
to go a day early with that thing this a
little bit later but then we vaccinated
with over plus poly IC plus the and
peptides are antagonists we could show
that in non tumor-bearing mice we can
actually using 01 listen and early
response we can get this significant
expansion of a cd8 positive cific a
positive T subpopulation if you just use
two were very nice and give it over you
lose that ability to expand your getting
a Munich's immunosuppressive effects in
the draining lymph nodes or the cervical
lymph nodes of the mouse however if you
give it our antagonist it should be aunt
Agnes I apologize you get a complete
or you get this expansion and we also
show that functionally you can overcome
the immune suppression the new
suppressive effect of what we're
thinking of soluble cd200 now we went
ahead with the help of them you know Dex
we got some debt ramires dr. Haley and
we showed that if we stained with these
debt rumors their specific for TC allah
that are so fickle positive or
reconfigured for San fickle you can see
that there's a nice TCR expansion on in
the draining lymph nodes of tumor beard
not to embarrass we lose that if we look
at the tumor left notes in tumor-bearing
animals and we can show that we can get
a regain this or we expand these cells
if we use our antagonists so
experimental model right now is actually
kind of 24 but what we're thinking is
that cd200 is secreted from the tumor
site and it actually acts on
antigen-presenting cells such as
monocytes mostly dendritic cells and
I'll go through this in a few minutes um
what we've shown by RNA seek analysis
that there's a nuclear factor nfat that
gets be phosphorylated and goes into the
to produce tnf-alpha and il-2 in the
nucleus however we're showing which
gives me that if we give the CD 200
protein we upregulate what's called ppi
a and this is awesome load a cycle fill
and a and what this does it in prevents
or inhibits the dephosphorylation
inhibiting translocation and inhibiting
the cytokines needed for progression to
an adopted response moreover PBIA down
regulates MHC class once so if we give
it that tagging asst we're showing that
we don't
an upregulation of these G's or
transcription of these genes we don't
get dephosphorylation as shown here of
enough 80 let me see if I can show that
a little bit better you don't get the
dephosphorylation of nfat nor do you get
the upregulation of ppi a so our
experiment model is the CD 200 inhibits
its grants or upregulates PBIA expands
in a ms in DFCS which results in immune
suppression however if we use our city
200 and tagging s receptor antagonists
we're still working on if it's binding
separate receptors or not but we're
hypothesizing is going through the
isoforms inducing a response which
induces suitable tosses cytokines
chemokines and ultimately mutagenicity
and i'll be showing you the data that
led to this hypothesis so earlier on and
this was actually published we showed
that if you use transwell place if you
use transwell plates and you put just 90
splenocytes on the bottom and you put
gliomas on the time with or without the
antagonists we can actually show that we
get an expansion of myeloid-derived
suppressor population cell population
and with our antagonists we actually get
inhibition of this or we don't get this
expansion and we just went ahead and
shoulder use no concentrations of a
protein plus or minus antagonist on
normal nine splenocytes and you can see
here that you can that you can inhibit
the expansion of myeloid-derived
suppressor cells
as well as Arjun ace production which
leads to immune suppression so we want
asked if this is happening in vivo so we
took glioma bearing mice and we
vaccinate them vaccinated them with
tumor license based off their glioma
cells with or without an antagonist and
what was interesting and we repeat this
a few times is that you get this
expansion of an empty SC population
about day 28 and this is where the mics
actually start dying however if we add
our antagonists you don't get this
expansion they actually go back down to
the population percentage of a naive
mouse and we show this multiple ways
that in vivo are two relays HR gliomas
induce are expandable idiocy population
and we can actually now block that
expansion using our antagonists so being
that we're focusing on
antigen-presenting cells we decided to
look at the seating levan beeze which
are monocytes so we purified these autos
on splenocytes and did RNA secret
positive with or without the antagonists
know to release a nova just antagonists
and you can see here with this rainbow
plot that you get multiple enhancement
and suppression in multiple genes within
the monocytes themselves so we started
asking questions what what are the
effects of our city toward receptor
antagonists on bone marrow-derived
dendritic cells so we purified them from
wild-type mice and we just passed them
with our aunt Agnes alone and we showed
that we got beautiful production of il-2
MIG mi 1 alpha 2 alpha gm-csf Iowa beta
and other cytokines with that taking us
alone we need is any kind of to release
a tour
nor did we use the adjuvant this is with
our antagonist alone we get a production
of cytokines interestingly we don't see
that monocytes however when you possible
to r 2 ER lysate with plus are
antagonists we get this expansion or a
synergetic expansion of multiple
cytokines and chemokines moreover if you
look on the spleens when you look when
you pause with ola you get over plus our
antagonists you get this increased
co-stimulatory expressions of cd80 86 as
well as it means c-class what so we
wanted to know if this is going to
enhance our mutagenicity so we went back
to a whole team one of mouse model and
we showed that if you pause while ty
splenocytes with over plus only i see
you come in with these transgenic OT
ones which are already has a TCR for the
synthehol you get some kind of a
response but if you add our antagonists
you get a significant enhancement in the
middle janessa t you don't get this if
you use a scrambled CDR and taking a
city 200 are antagonists this is just
our in-house nomenclature for it nor do
you get it if you have if you use cd200
receptor knockout animals moreover a day
20 posts to inoculation we harvested the
spleen sites we know sites in wild-type
or see georgia receptor knockout mice
treated with two or less a plus or minus
are taking us or our scrabble antagonist
and you can see that only and why in
wild-type mice with our antagonist she
got a significant announcement of a sign
of minik response in other words we took
the suite of sites harvest them
incubated them with our gliomas rgl 260
ones and we use this total cytotoxicity
assay developed I ICT and we showed that
that if you knock out the receptor or if
you use our scrambled or use just to
release it alone you get a significant
decrease in a cytolytic response now
we're repeating this but what was really
interesting was we could actually
differentiate apoptosis from necrosis or
cells that are that have undergone a
poptart apoptosis are becoming necrotic
using their total set of toxicity kit
that they're developing and this will
allow us to tease apart mechanisms so as
I said we're getting this enhancement of
chemotaxis or chemokines so we want to
look at chemotaxis now what we didn't do
that to accomplish that is we took
animals with no tumors these are just
non-tumor bearing animals and we treated
them with our antagonist saline or to
release it alone either one or 24 hours
later we came back and we vaccinated
them with saline for our saving group to
release a plus an edge of it for a tuber
lace a group or to release a plus
adjuvant plus our antagonists six hours
later we went ahead and harvested the
injection site so now we're looking
where we put down tetanus plus our
events and two releases this is this
actually is why we think that in the
beginning when I told you we have to use
the peptide an hour early this is why
what we saw here in saline is if we
looked in the capillaries and arteries
you virtually see just red blood cells
you don't see many lymphocytes however
one hour or a 24 hours later
you start seeing some infiltration of
lymphocytes we're on fetal typing needs
now when you give the mice the tumor
lacing however one hour with our
antagonists you see a significant
increase of lymphocytes infiltrating in
the tumor or in the vaccine site 24
hours later this is just chock-full of
leukocytes so like I said we're seeing
some of them look like polymorphonuclear
cells were phenotyping to see what's
coming in but were hypothesizing is that
this chemo traction this chemotaxis is
allowing the infiltration of
antigen-presenting cells monocytes and
dendritic cells to enhance antigen
update for to elicit an immuno response
and you can quantitate this if we took
eight different sections of skin and
just counted the cells that are
infiltrating we can show that that
antaeus I'm shy apologize again it's
mostly antagonist significantly enhance
chemotaxis or little leukocyte
infiltration into the area and we
repeated that showing that if you knock
out the receptor you don't get that so
all together somehow um I fix these
somehow they didn't get saved but all
together we show that using our
antagonists we can significantly
suppress or decrease tumor burden which
silly apologized which significantly
enhance survival of these animals
moreover we're showing that in our
breast tumor models we can significantly
we get almost eighty percent survival of
mice and what's these mice become tumor
free will we challenge them with
four million mt6 knows what we don't
have to vaccinate none of the tumors
will take post vaccination so are there
any questions right now because I'm
going to switch gears a little bit all
right so I'll go on now we're capable of
inducing an immune response now we think
we think we can significantly enhance
immunogenicity using our cd200 receptor
antagonists but there's more problems to
it the tumor microenvironment itself is
chock-full of multiple suppressor cells
t regulatory cells cytokines i attend
india season two cells etc etc but what
we found recently is this is virtual
force field around the tumor cells which
inhibit the infiltration of lymphocytes
are hypothesizing so remember before I
told you that high-grade ore these
gliomas gbms ependymomas medulloblastoma
have high transgressions levels of the
CD 200 well when we look further into
that we could see a brown in a dork in a
normal tissue cd200 stating but that
wasn't the case as I showed you earlier
in glioblastoma multiforme and these are
human samples but what caught my eye
with the help of a colleague of mine is
this we looked in the vasculature and
you can see here that normal brain
within the endothelial cells of the
blood vessels are basically have no
cd200 you see the city 200 outside of it
that's not the case in high-grade gbms
then high-grade gbms we get a lot of
cd200 expression
upregulation of cd200 in the endothelial
cells now remember this is extremely
real suppressive and it interacts on the
receptors and the receptors cd20
receptors are upregulated on T cells
moreover this is tumor-specific because
if you look here again on a GBM you can
see the city 200 but you don't see it
right next to the tomb yourself so this
appears to be within the tumor itself so
we're thinking now that this cd200
inhibits infiltration or differentiation
or differentiate cells into their
suppressor properties in other words
people have reported that it's this
interaction um interaction between the
tumor and activated t-cells which bear
the city 200 receptor this on cd4 c200
such a positive cells differentiates
into t regulatory cells and on cd8 they
just rather than dirt what we think that
that's happening at this spot right here
that they don't actually get into the
tumor microenvironment because of this
surrounding immunological force field
moreover the cd4 city 200 receptors
we're hypothesizing that we're testing
this hypothesis right now we think they
actually differentiate at this point
becoming t regulatory cells and then
they infiltrate into the
microenvironment inducing in a butyl
suppressive environment and the same is
true about tubers Oviatt of macrophage
we hypothesize that these become india
seas or in two cells and then they
infiltrate into the tumor
microenvironment and this is where we're
getting the infiltration of the
suppressant properties not by
interacting on the tumor itself because
we're showing that the two
self virtually has very little cd200 so
we wanted to test this theory and also
we want to know if we can overcome this
now as I said cd200 receptor is
upregulated on activated t-cells so I
wanted to protect the receptor so where
they go back into this area their block
and they can actually go into the tumor
microenvironment without becoming
suppressive or inactivated we go back
here so what I did is I actually make
antibody a polyclonal antibody against
the same epitope region as our
antagonist because we were afraid of
coming in there with just as I cd200
receptor and inducing a suppressive
response so we made these antibodies
against the specific regions of the city
200 as our antagonist we inoculated
tumors go ahead and do this we
inoculated tumors and then we gave it
the vaccines which contained cd200 or
tumor license to roll a 6 plus the
antagonist tumor lysis plus a scrambled
antagonist or to rely states plus
antagonist with the anti cd200 receptor
systemically on days 4 6 and 13 and
interestingly what we saw is when we
added the receptor with our antagonists
we actually got a significant inhibition
of tumor growth in that population
moreover by combining them we can see
that we had a significant enhancement in
survival now this particular experiment
we did get overall survival but we are
actually given antagonist 30 minutes
instead of one hour prior to vaccinate
and I think that's why we didn't see a
survival benefit with it alone but by
combining them we did see a significant
survival benefit so now we're making
monoclonal and we're testing this with a
monoclonal antibody so we decided we
wanted to translate this to a different
model so what we work with in
collaboration with a collaborative mind
dr. Elizabeth you are and Christopher
Cornell as we derive the canine specific
cd200 receptor antibodies we take these
dogs that come to the clinic okay we do
not give them tumors these dogs come to
the clinic demonstrating physiques and
we diagnose him with high-grade gliomas
we remove the gliomas and we make
vaccine to release it beats vaccine and
we added the antagonists to these
vaccines with this set of docs and what
we're showing is that the dogs really
exhibit some of them exhibit flu-like
symptoms which we've seen in our human
patients who respond to a beetle therapy
but what was really interesting is this
is one out of four now that we're having
a good response is that when this is
post of debulking you can see here you
can see here that in greed working right
now that about forty percent of the
tumor itself was left behind they were
only capable of removing approximately
sixty percent of the tumor four months
later it's gone the tubers God Monday
this dog had is eight month checkup and
the two are still gone moreover
interestingly we see a lot of parent
what we think is perivascular
infiltration of lymphocytes into the
tour site and we think that is
inhibiting the ability of these tumors
to
come back so we're comparing survival
fuss fire I did I didn't put it in this
presentation because it's a little bit
early but what we're showing is that
without treatment glioma dogs live
average about 50 days with too little
icing alone we have a calculation docks
that we've tested about 240 days is the
bead and they drop off there's about
what dog out of 16 that we're that's
still alive well similar dogs are 240 a
20 or 50 days out and we haven't bought
an eighty percent survival on this
ongoing clinical trial so we're able to
show in a murine that a few block this
checkpoint blockade using an antagonist
at the vaccine site we can significantly
enhance a deduction of an anti-tumor
response now given that CD to hundreds
um express highly expressed on the blood
endothelial cells in the GBM and we've
also shown this a melanoma breast cancer
we think that we need to use a receptor
antibody that will specifically block
the receptor without inhibiting the
activation of the cells or downregulated
the cells to allow it or to help it get
into the tumor microenvironment itself
and that with this combination therapy
will be able to significantly enhanced
immunogenicity of our immunotherapy
programs against CNS tumors as well as
in other tumors so I like to acknowledge
on people from my lab and collaborators
that have been helping me on this
project thank you very much thank you my
for bringing us that informative
presentation before we get to our
audience questions i just want to remind
everybody watching how they can submit
their questions you can submit a
question by typing it in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button the lower left and
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as possible we'll just give
our audience a minute to find a Q&A box
and type in a question that was an
excellent presentation Michael lots of
really good information there you think
we have a shy audience today I don't see
any questions coming in Michael perhaps
i could just turn it back over to you do
you have any other final comments for
our audience what we'd like to take from
like them to take from this presentation
so um so basically we're taking that
there to enhance our therapy of children
or tumor-bearing patients or patients
with diseases rather at CMS or other
tumors that we actually have a long way
to go to discover that magical cure and
that there's not going to be one I think
it's going to be a combination of
multiple checkpoint inhibitors at this
point that will increase the efficacy of
our immunotherapy the PDL one or the
pd-1 inhibitor is showing great promise
and that is addressing a suppressive
response at a whole complete different
site as our cd200 or ctla-4 so it's
going to be this combination
immunotherapies or these combination
checkpoint inhibitors that I feel we're
really going to make a difference in the
field we have derived two candidate or
two peptides that are human specific and
I didn't put that data in there I could
off but we're showing great in vitro
responses with them as well as
same as we did in the UM murie we're
seeing a huge cytokine and chemokine
production by taking immature dendritic
cells derived by cd4 t-cells and just
passing them with our city 200 receptor
antagonists so we actually have great
promise that this will be translatable
within a year or so and hopefully will
be in the clinic and make a difference
so exciting lots to do there good luck
with all that I'd like to thank dr.
Michael Owen for spending time with us
today and bringing us this information I
also like to thank today's sponsor
immuno chemistry technologies for making
this webcast possible I want to let our
audience know that they'll be receiving
an email from lab roots alerting them
when this webcast will be available to
split for me we play we do keep it
available on demand through May of 2016
so please forward that email to your
colleagues may miss today's live event
so they can get this information from
dr. Michael Owen thank you again for
joining us we'll see you next time
goodbye